[Musique]
l'île de la tentation revient à
invalider on va tous vos vies au l'île
de la tentation revient à la télévision
alors est ce une bonne idée ou pas on
vous a fait un petit récapitulatif
moi je vous le dit ma meuf est fait
l'île de la tentation frère écoute moi
bien elle rentre à la maison c'est une
île flottante là c'est parti
c'est chez nous c'est le retour de l'île
de la tentation à la télévision qu en
son second alors qu'aux états unis la
nouvelle version du programme vient
d'être lancé c'est sur w9 que l'émission
culte fera son retour
on rappelle le concept des couples se
rendre sur une île pour tester leur
fidélité ont été lancés en octobre
dernier le tournage devrait avoir lieu
au printemps et les premiers épisodes
pourraient être diffusés sur la chaîne à
la fin de l'été alors selon vous le
retour de l'île de la tentation est il
une bonne idée de la tentation alors je
vous dis ça va revenir sur w9 en prime
time
voilà ce sera lors de l'été 2010 neuf
donc l'été prochain donc moi je vais pas
partir en vacances parce que voilà juste
pour regarder ça je vous le dis c'était
des cartons d'audience et ya un extrait
donc on se lassera jamais ça celui où
brandon pète un plomb pour en découdre
avec un autre en place on regarde ça
jusqu'à pas mais l'on sait déjà le sait
déjà c'est parti il va péter les plombs
il cherche diana partout sur le site des
femmes armé d'un bâton pour affronter le
tentateur mettant cette fois en danger
le déroulement même de l'émission j'en
étais sûr bah oui c'est une boum à
signer les émissions cultes de thé
l'arrêter je compte encore mais j'ai pas
compris pourquoi ça s'est arrêté s'il
avait un peu des polémistes d'être trash
la mêlée moment rien que pour le feu de
camp où on montre la caméra ça avec
l'ipad on voit les images de sa farce et
foncer à quoi cet ipad et moodie gaulle
et non mais en plus on va rappeler le
principe c'est donc voilà vous êtes
tranquillement vous allez avec votre 9
et vous dit le principe est simple jean
pierre je te raconte garou se raconte
nice tu connais pas ces voiles atari
avec ta meuf et ta meuf vous allez dans
deux villes différentes toi sur une île
et ta meuf sur notre hymne et à des mecs
ou des meufs qui arrive en zodiac
tentateur des tentateurs ou des les
tentatrices voilà et/ou des tentacules
mêmes
il vous a rien fait il arrive en zodiac
alors ils sont habillés de la tête aux
pieds
voilà le boulot ni s'arrêter il arrive
vous sous la bourre pendant quinze jours
et changer l'état neuf ou ton mec est
donc après tu arrives tu as un mec qui
arrive sur l'autre île et qui a toutes
les images c'est comme quand photos par
exemple au beau match sinon j'ai merdé
s'il ya un mec qui arrive avec l'ipad
qui fait qu'un début
j'ai entendu tout simplement que je
voulais te battre
voilà je voulais me frotter à toi est ce
que vous voulez voir la suite ça mais si
ça va être incroyable c'est l'émission
l'île de la tentation - est-ce que c'est
possible aujourd'hui de remettre et de
la tentation à l'antenne il ya plein de
producteurs je vous dis et de patrons de
chaînes qui disent que c est une énorme
erreur parce qu'ils ont très peur avec
aujourd'hui le csa est très vigilant et
ils disent que ça tiendra pas géraldine
mois j'exècre ce programme
je trouve ma musique sacrée ouais je
trouve malsain et dévastateur les écrits
ont fait tout un plat un truc un peu
gadget un jeu une sorte de marivaudage
dans le porno light
alors évidemment pour jean mi qui adore
les string ficelle au chalet soirée
string ficelle champagne et sort de toi
de champagne non les drames conjugaux
tout en hystérie en insultes qui
pullulent monoï avec toute la évidemment
le stéréotype de la télé réalité où les
nanas sont forcément tout déplore deux
pouliches si les connaît et les gamins
and see on est tous là voyant des on
espère donc je déteste et je pense que
c'est catastrophique surtout pour les
jeunes partis nick était un vieux
monsieur il peut regarder ce moyen passé
par des filtres je vous dis dans les
rapports hommes femmes je trouve c'est
une cata lors il ya le patron de w9 qui
m'écrit qui nous regardent merci à
jérôme fouqueray qui me dit on vous
réserve de belles surprises sur prise ça
va être une belle émission
bon allez dis que ça va être une belle
émission et qu'ils ont tout contrôler je
vous le dis moi j'ai confiance en double
up et moi j'ai très envie de la voir le
point de lescar concept clair aux est
alléchant et pour moi c'était la
première émission phare de la télé
réalité mais c'était formidable à
regarder moi je me saisir les germes le
soleil mâchonne termine jamais quoi bon
moi le sexe thème le soleil j'ai adoré
regarder ça elle aime le sexe elle aime
le soleil
malheureusement non mais pour être très
sérieuse
il ya eu des pâles copies il ya des
erreurs et des tentations ce n'est plus
que ça sur les chaînes et là on revient
au programme originel
donc oui évidemment retour de reynald en
question alors très vite
ce qui me révolte ne sait pas que
francesca même parce que ça m'étonne pas
du tout c'est que vous aimiez syrie où
est pas aimé cette émission c'est une
émission vulgaire oui à l'époque
d'aujourd'hui mais c'est pas lui c'est
pas les producteurs qui vont être
remplacés télé semaine et la somme
qu'ils ont manifesté devant de la scène
si l'émission est possible celui et moi
je suis fou de la tentation bonne ou
mauvaise idée on va voir tout juste
compenser téléspectateurs je vous le dis
voilà bonne à
[Rires]
façon je voulais dire à la stricte
vérité
j'étais pas complètement givrée j'ai
vraiment voulu freiner à l'autre j'étais
pas pour du toit